[Music]  in many African countries people don't  have access to the power grid instead  they have to rely on generators the  problem is they're loud they need diesel  and they pollute the air the  berlin-based startup son Ziller offers  an alternative it's built a portable  solar kit that can replace the generator  it consists of an inverter a battery a  sail with solar panels and a couple of  cables transport setup and maintenance  are easy  [Music]  the kid can supply and store electricity  for up to seven people at a price of two  thousand seven hundred euros the system  doesn't come cheap but the engineer say  it lasts much longer than a generator